hey this is presh talwalkar
a rectangle has sides of six and eight
construct a diagonal of the rectangle
dividing the rectangle into two
triangles
inscribe circle x in one triangle and
circle y in the other triangle
the question is what is the length of x
y
the distance between the two circles
centers
i thank diviesce for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
here's one way to solve the problem
construct a right triangle where one leg
is the vertical distance between x and y
and the other leg is the horizontal
distance between x and y
then x y is the hypotenuse of this right
triangle
in circle x construct radii to the
tangency points with the rectangle
let r be the length of the radius
do the same thing for circle y
now construct the following two line
segments from the other corner of the
right triangle
each of these line segments has length
equal to r
then the shorter leg of the right
triangle has length equal to 6 minus 2r
and the longer leg has a length equal to
8 minus 2r
thus the length of the hypotenuse is
equal to the square root of the sum of
the squares of the lengths of the legs
all that remains is to solve for r
the radius of the inscribed circle
let's solve for that now
let's focus on one half of the rectangle
this right triangle has legs equal to
six and eight which means its hypotenuse
is equal to ten
the area of half of the rectangle is
equal to six times eight divided by two
which is equal to twenty-four
there's another way that we can solve
for the area of half the rectangle
construct the following radius of circle
x to the tangency point with the
diagonal of the rectangle
we'll now construct three triangles
this triangle has a base equal to six
and a height equal to r
so its area is equal to six r over two
this triangle has a base equal to eight
and a height equal to r so its area is
equal to eight r over two
this triangle has a base equal to ten
and a height equal to r which means its
area is ten r over two
the sum of these three areas is equal to
r times the semi perimeter of the
triangle which is also equal to twelve
times r
this is also equal to half the area of
the rectangle
thus we have twelve r is equal to
twenty-four
we divide both sides of the equation by
twelve to get that r is equal to two
we now substitute in for our formula for
x y
this means x y is equal to the square
root of 2 squared plus 4 squared and
that's equal to the square root of 20
which is approximately equal to
4.472 and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time